I think anybody who's lost somebody's
close to them understands that that is
what you want I know it's difficult but
Lauren can you take me back to that day
into that to that boat ride you started
off those sunny Fairlady clouds in the
sky but when we got halfway through done
with the duck boat thing there was some
evil clouds the wind started picking up
I saw a tree fall down in the background
and told my brother you didn't notice it
I was freaking out the boat started
leaning towards the left not left-right
and that was and my mom called right
before hep yeah just to check in well
because I was away from them and I
noticed the weather getting bad and of
course I knew where they were and so I
called I believe it was like 7:00
shortly after salmon and just to check
on them and Steve said I said are you on
the like yes and I said you know why and
he says well it wasn't the weather
wasn't bad when we left but it's gotten
bad Lauren what happened at that point
when your dad hung up with your mom
water started flooding through the boat
right before his sake everybody was in
shock
the guy didn't tell us to put on life
jackets he wasn't shocked to tell what
happened when you got mine when you did
get in the water Lauren your dad hung up
at that point and he said not to put the
lifejackets on how it was water coming
into the boat at that point everybody
was in shock they're the nicest people
in that boat there's a lot of old people
we're surrounded by them three ones in
front of us and then the how did you
make it out
No
do you remember how you got to safety
once you were in the water and you'd
gotten to the surface those people
I remember clinging on for that side you
know the port from deck or whatever's on
the book on the boat
well not boat but this one the land
connects to the boat okay on the dock
yeah we were hanging some people were
hanging on everyday life so had you swam
over did you swim over there no way
Julie push me there
I got scrapes from it alright got
scraped on my toe I don't remember how I
did that I know that they're just
beginning their investigation are you
angry
do you have questions I'm not I'm not
going to say I'm angry I you know I do
have questions you know there's with any
case anything you there's always the
wise and you know was there negligence
I don't know you know and the other
storm came so suddenly what didn't what
is it called Turkish truck what about
the company that owns the duck boat so
when we were going through it he he
barely used any time to explain how to
put them on maybe like two seconds and
then went back to talking about people
oh look who is he texting is that your
girlfriend
so when so we need you you know when you
got on the boat did they give you any
type of safety advice tell you what to
do about it like a few seconds but they
didn't you really use much time yeah and
I think - I mean that was my thing if
the life check is needed to be readily
accessible even in you know if you're on
an airplane they easily come down to me
it's there should be something similar
to that on on the Ducks if you should
have to get up and get them could you
have reached them Lauren if you had
stood up if you were able to stand up
i shortened which is a problem if that
that is I mean huh and I know a lot of
people don't want to wear life jackets
but to me they needed the life jackets
on before they reached even whinnying
because although my son could swim
Lauren could swim and my husband can
swim
obviously the currents and maybe the dad
I don't I don't know what the factors
are because we when we've seen that
we've seen the boats obviously they
weren't on the water but with that roof
that's over it so when you were trying
to get out how are you able to get out
that plastic thing to protect us from
the water spraying on us from the wind
getting in her eyes
that really hurt so they finally moved
the things down eventually he started
sinking
we had to shove that out of the way so
was that a like above you like the roof
canopy part no it was on the sides you
could just make him down I don't
remember if they bashed him down but
they were hard to move and so you got
out the side essentially I thought it in
that deep of water you can't really tell
which ways which so I started banging on
the roof it came off I think I'm gonna
and then I just gave up and went towards
some different direction I made it
through could you see anything at that
point or was it it was completely full
you know just murky water I know I
swallowed a lot of it trying to breathe
I inhaled it how are you say it and then
when you came up to the surface
how long you said the the waves kind of
carried you do you know how long from
when you came up to when you got do you
remember that felt like forever
they were just moving me closer and
moving me farther and closer eventually
I just thought to myself I need to go I
need that I need safety so I gave
everything I got to get the last
do you think all people could have feed
through that were you escaped so it
wasn't a very big area that you were
able to get it was just on one side I
think and then you would hit things have
you tried to go out through the back way
I think it might get tangled up and all
that stuff
I'm afraid my dad did he has heart
troubles but the grandpa yeah dad bad
him to eat more bananas I won't have a
heart attack I'm afraid he might have
had one there